- [Tutor] A Pap test
is a test to screen for cervical cancer
or other cervical diseases.
Your cervix is the
lower part of the uterus
at the top of your vagina.
A Pap test is used to check
your cervix for abnormal cells.
Abnormal cells can sometimes
turn into cervical cancer
if they aren't treated.
A Pap test can be part of a pelvic exam.
First, your healthcare provider
will place an instrument called
a speculum into your vagina.
The speculum will be opened
so that your cervix can be seen.
Next, your provider will
use a scraper or brush
to gently collect cells from your cervix.
Your cells will be examined
at a lab under a microscope
to see if any of them are abnormal.
It usually takes about one to three weeks
to get your test results.
If you have questions about this test
or your test results,
talk to your provider.